alrighty so we're here and valentine's
day is fast approaching it's time for us
here at the ben shapiro show to write
some valentines to our favorite people
this video is sponsored by ring.com so
let's just begin
to governor ron desantis thank you for
letting me come to this beautiful state
mainly to escape the horror that is
california
also the weather is really nice can you
shoot a nuclear weapon at a hurricane
we'll have to see
two gavin newsom happy
valentine's day you look like a ken doll
and also like a ken doll you are pliable
enough to fit your head
entirely up your own ass you are a truly
horrible governor
so thanks for driving me from my birth
state
i let my guard down and i apologize for
it
two jen
[Music]
you are so refreshing
in your dedication
to truth just kidding i'm lying
just like you i'm just gonna reject the
premise of the question
to hollywood i'm sad
you don't make good movies
much anymore so we will
to la mayor eric garcetti
you stupid face you took my home city
and you ruined it and now you want
praise well
go blow it out your ass new piece of
greetings from florida
two black lives matter
thanks for burning down
the local foot locker for racial justice
i didn't like that store anyway
2 cardi b i sincerely
hope you found a bucket and a mop
for your wet ass p word corona
don't you still remember the lyrics dear
hillary
and bill i wish you another year
of love joy togetherness and deep
abiding affection that's what marriage
is truly
all about i learned that from you
[Music]
dear constitution i love you
more than words can express
i'm sorry you're going through a rough
time it'll be
over soon i mean the country
[Music]
2 ibram candy i'm only
writing this so you won't
call me racist but i
think that's going to make you
call me a racist
dear official daily
wire dog jasper i hate you
more than i thought humanly possible
i know you feel the same you vicious
anti-semite
dear president biden from full of
pressure true international pressure to
my sponsors at ring.com
thanks for protecting my family this
year
and they can protect your family too so
much happens at our front door that's
one thing that has not changed
these days at my house i'm getting more
packages more visitors
it's never been more important to be
able to see who is there or what is
happening
that's why it's the perfect time to
upgrade your doorstep with a ring video
doorbell with ring
you can see and speak to whoever is at
the door from anywhere right on your
phone you'll never miss a visit whether
it's your neighbor
your dinner or your groceries and you
can keep those packages and deliveries
safe
with motion detection you'll get
notified even if they don't ring the
doorbell if somebody stops by or
something is going on
ring will let you know i use ring at my
house to keep track of my three
wild children you will need ring for the
same purpose if you have
children i love having the ring video
doorbell i've actually added some ring
security cameras all
around the home no matter your home ring
has everything you need to protect it
see and speak to whoever is at your door
from anywhere with those video doorbells
and keep an eye on every corner
of your house with those easy to install
indoor and outdoor cams
and protect your whole home with ring
alarm to powerful affordable whole home
security system you can easily install
yourself right now get a special offer
on the ring welcome kit at ring.com
ben shapiro it comes with the ring video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro
the perfect way to upgrade your front
door and start your ring experience so
go to ring.com ben shapiro that's
ring.com
ben shapiro thanks ring there's one
other twist to this video okay
so we had uh daily wire members write
you guys
okay people on all access
wrote valentine's notes yeah that's
funny some of the daily wire members
have written me valentine's which is
both charming and extraordinarily creepy
so i mean frankly i'm a little flattered
i didn't get any of these for like my
entire childhood little late guys but
thanks timothy writes
hey ben thank you so much for what you
do i discovered your show two years ago
in early 2019.
i was a leftist socialist who's
beginning to question my political
ideology upon discovery of your show
i realized how wrong i was and how i had
been lied to by politicians like bernie
sanders i thank you for all you have
done
and hope for your continued success in
the future i hope you and your wife have
a happy valentine's day
it's very sweet timothy thank you
what's the best way to make kosher
pickles by soaking cucumbers in a
leftist tears tumbler
filled with leftist tears happy
valentine's day to my favorite jewish
commentator
that's very sweet and an excellent way
to make kosher pickles hey ben happy
valentine's day please don't say my name
on air for all the libs to hear
i don't want them to cancel me for
knowing you exist anonymous
thanks dad dear ben may this valentine's
bring you as much happiness to you as
your amazing impressions
brought to us only your morphed
pre-pubescent voice can truly capture
the essence of that commie bernie
sanders
and it is only that pragmatic humor of
yours that makes this crazy political
world we live intolerable happy
valentine's day regards
mr and mrs foxx of pflugerville texas
conservatives are red liberals are blue
i would have gone crazy
if it were not for you your logic and
reason are so damn appealing
all the facts that you share are giving
me feelings mark g
kenneth square pennsylvania that's
beautiful i mean
guys i need admit hey baby facts don't
care about your feelings
but i sure should do my favorite one of
these stories is somebody was like
i was with my girlfriend and she kept
saying like she really looked ugly that
day like she kept hey like i'm ugly i
look so terrible
and then i was like yeah well you know
what facts don't care about your
feelings
it's like oh that's a solid comeback
that is it that is an excellent use that
is an excellent use
uh like it is using my tagline as a tool
of seduction is definitely a new it's
definitely a new take
thanks to everybody who subscribes over
at dailywire.com particularly are all
excess
members for sending me those wonderful
wonderful valentines they
warmed my heart to the extent it can
never be warmed it's been thawed just a
little bit so
back into the freezer it goes i hope you
have a wonderful valentine's day
and we will see you here at the next
holiday presumably
president's day or something